the 94th annual academy awards are
finally here and all of our favorite
stars are bringing their fashion a game
to the red carpet every year oscar
guests highlight a certain cause by
wearing a ribbon or a button this year
it's a blue ribbon in support of
refugees who have fled ukraine the
ribbons are distributed by the u.n
refugee agency with the hashtag with
refugees featured on the side jamie lee
curtis who will be presenting during the
show makes a statement with the blue
ribbon featured on her hand paired with
the stunning navy blue mesh gown by
stella mccartney diane warren also
showed her support by placing a ribbon
on the lapel of her eye-catching green
suit and jason momoa found a way to show
his support opting to wear a blue and
gold pocket square now let's get to some
of my favorite looks of the night purple
seems to be the color of the evening
with king richard star demi singleton
lighting up the red carpet in this
custom lilac miu dress featuring floral
crystal embellishments demi's co-star 15
year old sanaya sydney is giving us real
life princess vibes in this floral adorn
strapless number by armani prive
meanwhile pam and tommy star lily james
went with baby pink in the sexy versace
gown featuring thigh high slits now
let's just all take in front runner
jessica chastain's breathtaking gucci
dress i mean she's already a winner with
this look it's giving us all the mermaid
vibes and i love it the dramatic ruffle
detailing at the bottom definitely
completes the look now over to lupita
nyong'o who looks like a real-life oscar
in this gold product gown i absolutely
love it what were some of your favorite
looks on the red carpet let us know with
the comments below